>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, DC.
>> And I'll be the host for today's session.
And as you may know, this program is
part of a series of webinars connected
to the library's exhibition, Echoes of the
Great War: American Experiences of World War I,
which is on view here at the
library through January of 2019.
Today's presentation will
last approximately 30 minutes.
There's time after that for our presenter,
Sahr Conway-Lanz to answer questions.
Please note that you can
communicate with us by the chat.
If you've already introduced yourself, that's
great, and if you haven't please take a minute
to tell us who you are and
where you're joining from.
It's also a chance for you to
test out how the chat works.
Make sure you're sending to all participants.
There's a little chat icon at
the top of the WebEx event center
that you can click to access the chat.
Again, submit questions throughout the
session and Sahr will answer them at the end.
If you have technical questions,
please send a message
to Cathy McWiggin who's our
technical host for the day.
We'll be recording today's
session which will then be posted
on the library's website once
the program has been captioned.
So today's presenter, as I
mentioned, is Sahr Conway-Lanz.
He's a historian in the manuscript division.
He holds a PhD in history from Harvard
University and is co-curator of the exhibition,
Echoes of the Great War, and is also the curator
for the Woodrow Wilson papers
here at the library.
Sahr's talk is titled, Woodrow
Wilson Chooses War.
Thanks so much, Sahr, for
being here and presenting.
I'll pass it to you to take over.
>> Thank you, Naomi.
And thanks to the rest of
you for joining us today.
As Naomi mentioned, I work as a historian
in the manuscript division helping to build
and facilitate use of the
library's archival collections --
personal, family, and organizational
papers of lasting historical value.
I specialize --
In the library's Foreign Policy, Military,
and International Collections concerning --
The 20th and 21st century American history.
Since one of the collections I curate
is the papers of Woodrow Wilson,
I'm glad to have this opportunity to talk
with you about Woodrow Wilson and his decision
to lead the United States into World War One.
Give me just one second.
I'm catching up with the presentation.
Alright. There we go.
So we know that President
Woodrow Wilson chose war in 1917,
as the Atlanta Journal shows us here.
But you may be surprised that even experts
are not terribly confident about why, how,
or when Wilson changed his mind and
decided to lead the United States
from the three-year-long policy of
neutrality in the first World War
to a a policy of full-fledged belligerency.
The entire question of why the United States
entered World War I many today have forgotten,
and for good reason.
The explanations are not
easy to understand today,
at least not the way historians
have often explained them.
I want to try and do three things
with this talk: explore the mystery
of Woodrow Wilson's decision, examine
what Wilson and others said was at stake
in choosing war, and explain its
significance for them, hopefully in terms
that will be more easily grasped by us today.
I also want to discuss the relation of the
collections here at the library and a few
of the items in the exhibit --
all items that I'm showing are
from the exhibit -- to those larger questions.
Let us start with the question of why we don't
have more confidence in the answers to the why,
how, and when of Wilson's decision for war.
After all, the Library of Congress has a
very large collection of Wilson's papers --
about 600 feet of them if you
line up the files on a shelf.
Almost 300,000 documents.
Drawing largely but not exclusively from
the papers here at the Library of Congress,
Princeton professor Arthur Link spent 35 years
editing Wilson's papers and published 69 volumes
of primary source material on
Wilson's life and presidency.
With all this source material,
how can anyone possibly be unsure
about such a momentous decision?
Well it has a lot to do with Wilson himself.
Wilson rarely reflected on himself and his work
in writing, unlike many other well-known figures
such as Theodore Roosevelt or George Patton,
whose papers we also have here at the library.
Most of Wilson's writings --
especially as president --
are public-facing, such as his speeches.
Even his official and private letters were
often short and contained little explanation
of his thinking on major decisions.
Moreover, Wilson never gave a detailed
account of his decision for war.
His health after the war is surely part of this,
but he also explicitly refused to write memoirs.
In 1920 he said, there are -- quote --
biographies, autobiographies,
and ought not to biographies.
Whether mine ought to be
or not, they will not be.
The fact that we don't have obvious
answers about Wilson's choice
for war makes the question more
intriguing for me, and I hope for you too,
and I think underlines the importance of the
collection to the library and other archives
that help us explore this question.
After all, what is more important than
a country's decision to go to war?
So what can we learn from these archival
materials about Wilson choosing war?
I want to start with this exhibit item, just
a page here but it's from Wilson's April 2nd,
1917 war address where the president is
urging congress to recognize the state of war
between the United States and Germany.
So specifically this item is one page
of Wilson's reading copy of that address
from his papers here at the Library of Congress.
The address lays out Wilson's
public rationale for war.
In the speech, Wilson leads off by condemning
the German decision two months earlier
in February, 1917, to resume
unrestricted submarine warfare.
Wilson describes it as Germany's -- quote --
purpose to put aside all
restaurant of law and humanity.
End quote.
And he used submarines to sink every ship
approaching Britain or any other allied port.
Submarine attacks had been an issue
for the United States since 1915.
Britain during World War I dominated the seas
and blockaded Germany and the central powers.
Germany viewed its use of
submarines as justified retaliation
for Britain's -- quote -- starvation blockade.
In retaliation, the Germans were trying to
blockade Britain with the use of their uboats.
However, neutral American shipping or
American property and passengers on neutral
or allied ships were in danger from
these German submarine attacks.
Wilson and others insisted on the right
of Americans to trade and travel freely
without risk of harm from Germany's subs
and protested German attacks without warning
on shipping that killed passengers and
merchant crews and destroyed trade goods.
These attacks without warning constituted
the so-called unrestricted submarine warfare.
In his war address, Wilson then
talks about how other alternatives
like arming merchant shipping are not workable
and that the German government
has proven itself untrustworthy,
implying that further negotiations
are pointless.
Wilson's most famous line
in this document is, quote,
the world must be made safe for democracy.
In the page that you see here
displayed you can see that very line.
But if you read the entire
speech closely you will find
that Wilson is not clearly calling
for a war to spread democracy.
I would argue Wilson has often
been misunderstood on this point.
Wilson's point here is that anti-democratic,
autocratic Germany has proven itself a threat
to citizens of democracy like the United
States through its submarine warfare
and other perfidious behavior,
and therefore must be fought.
While other Americans were advocating at the
time a war to create a more democratic world,
Wilson was not clearly offering that
justification for war in this speech.
That left as Wilson's primary public
justification for war the right of Americans
to travel on foreign ships entering a war zone.
Let's explore this justification further.
Let's look at the question of why Wilson
had become convinced that war was necessary
to protect the principle of free travel and
trade, often referred to at the time as freedom
of the seas or in wartime
as the rights of neutrals.
Ultimately, the question is, if Wilson was
not being entirely frank with the public
about his true motivations for going to
war, why did Wilson use this principle
as his public justification when
he really was after something else?
Historians have come up with a variety of
explanations for Wilson's decision for war.
There's an older, economic argument about
Wilson's choice which more recently has fallen
out of favor and I'm happy to discuss it
during questions if anyone is interested.
But I'm going to focus on the
two currently dominant arguments.
Probably the most common explanation offered
today for Wilson's choice for war was his vision
and ambitions for a new, peaceful, international
order, nothing less than a drastic reform
of international relations -- essentially
American progressivism brought to the world.
There are various versions of this argument
but it generally goes that Wilson was disgusted
with what he saw as a catastrophic world
war and the treacherous and selfish politics
of the empires and monarchies of Europe.
He wanted to change how states behaved
in the international system
and bring a new era of peace.
This is where we get the phrase, the war
to end war or the war to end all wars,
which is often associated with Wilson even
though H.G. Wells was the one to coin the phrase
and Wilson did not make much use of the phrase
in public speeches or his private writings.
Wilson usually talked instead of establishing
peace or sometimes permanent peace.
Wilson thought a key ingredient to this new
world order would be a league of nations
which could help resolve conflicts among
states and help to maintain the peace.
Here being displayed is Wilson's first
draft of the League of Nations Covenant,
what would be the governing constitution
of this new international organization.
So the argument goes that Wilson chose
war because he finally became convinced
that the US could do more to shape the
post-war peace and pursue his vision
by fighting than by remaining neutral.
There's much to this argument.
Certainly Wilson did develop a dramatic
new vision of international relations
and this is one reason he's
well remembered today.
But the argument has some weaknesses
in explaining why Wilson chose war.
The big problem is chronology.
There simply is not much evidence that
Wilson is thinking about going to war
for his peaceful ends until after he asks
congress to declare war on April 2nd.
The day Germany declares unrestricted
submarine warfare on February 1st,
1917 (two months before), Wilson
is still worrying that going
to war will ruin American chances
to help establish a post-war peace.
Wilson's close advisor, Edward House, in his
diary for that day wrote, the president --
quote -- reiterated his belief that it would be
a crime for this government to involve itself
in the war to such an extent as to make
it impossible to save Europe aftward.
In fact, the first evidence we
have of Wilson making the argument
that fighting will allow the US to better
influence the peace is from a meeting he has
with the peace advocate Jane Adams
later that month on February 28th.
This is when Wilson already knows
about the Zimmerman telegram.
Here's a cartoon about the
scandal surrounding the telegram.
So Wilson already knows about the German
intrigues to start a war between Mexico
and the United States, and by this
time the archival evidence suggests
that Wilson has lost all faith in ending
the war for negotiating with the Germans.
In other words, Wilson loses all faith
in the Germans before he starts thinking
that fighting could be his best
option for creating post-war peace.
In addition, Wilson's war address on April
2nd that I was discussing earlier does not lay
out Wilson's vision for a post-war
order or a scheme for ending all wars,
even though it sometimes has
been taken to imply this.
I would argue the address as a
whole, as well as other evidence
from the manuscript collections we
have here at the library and elsewhere,
does not support this interpretation even though
today it's popular to think that Wilson went
to war to establish a new
world order or to end all war.
I think it more likely that Wilson
made the connection between his ideas
about establishing a peaceful order and
how fighting could lead to that peaceful,
post-war world as an afterthought
to choosing war.
In other words, he came to view this new global
system as the silver lining to the cloud of war
and that it was not what
motivated him to choose to fight.
That brings us to the other major
explanation for why Wilson chose war.
This is the argument I find most convincing.
It's the case he is explicitly
making in his war address.
It's the argument that Wilson went to war
over a principle: the right of Americans
and other neutrals during war
to travel freely overseas.
Now you may be thinking, how could this
possibly be the reason the US went to war,
a war in which over 100,000
Americans lost their lives?
What was Wilson possibly thinking?
How could war be worth the
right to travel overseas,
especially to travel overseas in a war zone?
You would think most people would not
be clamoring for the right to sail
into a deadly war zone swarming with submarines.
Well, the first thing to understand is that
Wilson's concern was not so much about travel
or even abstract rights than that Wilson
believed he needed to stand up for a principle
that he had laid out publicly
and pledged his support for.
Wilson had told the Germans as early as 1915
that the US would enforce this principle
which most saw as part of established
international law and custom.
When the British passenger ship the
Lusitania was sunk in May, 1915 --
killing over 100 Americans and over
1,000 others -- the headline's here.
Although you'll note that initial
press reports said that all were saved.
But when the Lusitania sunk, Wilson threatened
to break diplomatic relations with Germany
if the Germans continued with their
submarine attacks without warning
on passenger and merchant vessels.
In effect, Wilson had laid down a red line
that he hoped the Germans would not cross --
a warning so likely to lead to war that
Wilson's anti-war Secretary of State,
William Jennings Bryan, resigned in
protest over Wilson's threat in 1915.
Why the United States did not
go to war for two more years is
because Germany did largely back off from its
unrestricted submarine warfare until early 1917.
Wilson used this time to try to help
negotiate a peaceful end to the war
and I think the archival evidence clearly
shows his hope was that he would not have
to enforce his threat, and the evidence
amply demonstrates his reluctance
to lead the United States into war.
But he also acknowledged
that his official warning
to Germany basically left the
possibility of war up to the Germans.
Wilson's Secretary of the Navy recalled the
president telling him during the 1916 election
-- quote -- I can't keep the country out of war.
They talk of me as though I were a god.
Any little German lieutenant can put us into
war at any time by some calculated outrage.
Wilson had helped to create the possibility of
war by his resolve to stand up for a principle
and this left the coming
of war to outside forces.
Wilson, in the leadup to war, often expressed
himself in public and private as believing
that external forces were
driving the US toward war.
And Wilson seemed to experience the coming
of war as out of his control, and eventually,
probably, in late February, 1917, as inevitable.
But you may still have the question of
why did Wilson and other Americans --
because congress did ultimately support going
to war -- feel that standing by this principle,
even if it was a principle embedded in
international law, was important enough
to justify the terrible consequences of war?
Historians usually characterize the
importance of this stand on freedom of the seas
and neutral rights to Wilson
and others as the importance
of maintaining American international
credibility, prestige, or honor.
That is, if Wilson had not
enforced his principled pledge,
the United States would have lost influence,
especially moral influence, in the world.
And I think this is largely the
explanation for why Wilson chose war.
But I also think that one of the reasons why
people today often forget or are confused
by explanations for US entry into World War I,
which focus on the right to travel and freedom
of the seas and neutral rights and
American credibility and prestige,
is because those intertwined explanations lose
sight of why Wilson drew his principled red line
in the first place, why he became trapped into
feeling compelled to defend US credibility
when German subs resumed
their indiscriminate attacks.
And this brings us back to the Lusitania
and the American lives lost there.
To Wilson and many Americans,
standing up for the freedom of the seas
and neutral rights was standing
against inhumane attacks
on innocent people uninvolved
in the European war.
Wilson in his war address characterized the
primary German offense as, quote, the wanton
and wholesale destruction of
the lives of non-combatants.
Men, women, and children engaged
in pursuits which have always --
even in the darkest periods of modern history
-- been deemed innocent and legitimate.
This is an issue that's still
very much with us today.
And I think it's easier for us to grasp
even if we don't agree with Wilson.
To Wilson, Germany had committed an
atrocity against civilians in violation
of humanitarian standards and had to be held
accountable for that offense and prevented
from committing further atrocities
against Americans.
This explanation also helps us to understand
the power of the enlist poster that you see
on the screen with its image of a woman
with a child in her arms drowning.
This is not to say that Wilson
was right to go to war.
The war had a terrible toll
for the United States.
The Allies killed non-combatants as well and
the first world war was followed by a second.
I will leave that judgment of Wilson's
decision up to you but I hope you'll agree
that understanding the reasons the United
States went to war in 1917 is important
and that the Library of Congress'
collections, which were the basis for my talk,
are essential to that understanding.
Thank you.
And Naomi, I'll turn it back over to you.
>> Great. Thanks so much, Sahr,
for that fascinating talk.
And for those who are interested, especially
in the collections, in some of the images
that you've shown, you should know
that many of those are available
on our website at loc.gov/exhibits.
Those are from the exhibition so if you're
not able to come here to the library,
you can certainly see them in
the online exhibition format.
So now we'll open it up for
questions so please tell us what you'd
like to know from Sahr in the chat.
Make sure you're sending it to all participants.
We're happy to take questions
for five or ten minutes.
I think I'll begin, though, Sahr, with a general
question for you about the library's collection.
So how is it that the library
came to hold the Wilson papers
and then how do researchers
generally access them?
As the main curator for the Wilson papers,
tell us a little bit about the life
of those papers here at the library.
>> So actually shorter after Woodrow Wilson
left office, the Library of Congress embarked
on a major effort to collect presidential
papers, including Woodrow Wilson's.
And so in the early 20th century, a number
of presidential paper collections were
brought to the Library of Congress.
Wilson's were donated by his family and some
of them came directly from the White House.
And the Library of Congress has been a major
repository for presidential papers ever since.
We have the papers of 23 American presidents.
The most of the 20th century presidents after
Calvin Coolidge now have presidential libraries
where you can use the presidential papers.
And those presidential libraries
are run by the national archives.
But for presidential collections
before Herbert Hoover,
most of those papers can be
found at the Library of Congress.
Now if you're interested in actually
using the Woodrow Wilson papers,
there are a couple of ways that you can do this.
Most of the Wilson papers have been microfilmed
and so they are available for use on microfilm.
But I know microfilm is not
necessarily the easiest thing to use
so there are a couple of other options.
One is in the not-too-distant future --
in the spring or summer of next year --
the Woodrow Wilson papers
will be available online.
They're in the process of being digitized
and put on the Library of Congress' website.
And so they will -- all of the
Wilson papers here at the Library
of Congress will be available on the
website in about six months or so.
Another option for using the papers --
you won't get to see the images of the
original papers this way, but those 69 volumes
of the papers of Woodrow Wilson
by Arthur Link that I mentioned
in my talk are really the most accessible
way today, tomorrow, for the next six months,
of getting access to many of the most important
papers from the Woodrow Wilson collection.
And even though it's 69 volumes, it's not
anywhere close to the entire collection,
all 300,000 documents that we
have at the Library of Congress.
But remember that not every document in
the Woodrow Wilson papers was written
by Woodrow Wilson or gives you a deep insight
about him, his life, and his presidency.
Does that answer your question, Naomi?
>> It does.
Thank you.
And it's very exciting, as Connie
says, to have digital access
in the coming months for the Wilson papers.
So another question -- and I encourage all of
you guys who are listening to also submit one,
but I'll give you one more, Sahr, which
is to ask you about Wilson's influence
on American foreign policy and how or whether
it shaped American foreign policy today.
Sort of this idea of an international
perspective, international bodies,
and the United States involvement
in those bodies and sort of a frame
for American foreign policy
the last century or so.
Are we moving out of an era of Wilsonism today?
How would you talk about that?
>> So you know, Wilson is not necessarily
the most popular president today
but I think he is very important both
for domestic policy and foreign policy.
In foreign policy, it's really where he made
his mark although I think it would have been a
surprise to Wilson to think
that international relations is
where he really would have
had the greatest influence.
But in international relations,
kind of how people often think
about Wilson still today is
Wilson really embodied this idea
of idealism in international affairs.
And it's a question that people
come back to again and again dealing
with today's current events
and thinking about the history
of American foreign relations
and Wilson in particular.
I mean, this idea of Wilsonianism, a term that
has been used to mean many different things,
although generally it's used to mean the idea
of pursuing some kind of universal ideals
as opposed to narrow American
self-interest or narrow national interests.
It's also been used to mean
the spread of democracy abroad,
which in my talk I said I think that's
slightly a misreading of Woodrow Wilson,
even though he did pick up the chance for
self-determination during World War I and follow
that through to a certain degree.
Although, Wilson certainly wasn't arguing to
get rid of imperialism and colonies dominated
by the European powers throughout the world.
He had somewhat ambivalent views about that.
But in terms of whether we're
leaving an era of Wilsonianism,
I think it's going to be -- I mean, yeah.
I'm a historian.
One of the last things you want me to do is make
predictions about the future but I would say
that considering questions about
the role of ideals versus interest
and international relations is going to
be a question that we're going to continue
to struggle with for the foreseeable future.
>> Alright.
Thank you for that.
We have had one -- oh, go ahead.
Sorry.
>> Oh, go ahead.
Go ahead.
>> Well, just that we had another.
We had a question come through,
a similar question
that also asks you to predict [laughing].
So maybe this is another one that,
you know, it's hard to answer.
But Trevor asks, on hearing of US entry, Lloyd
George said the US had become a superpower.
Is this the end of the American century?
Well I'm always happy to put
on my political science hat
and try to make predictions
about what is coming.
But this is actually a parlor game that --
you know, that end of the American century
that's very popular among historians
and academics and political
scientists in general and,
you know, talking heads in the press.
And I would just point out -- I mean,
I don't have any particular
insight in that, I would venture.
But I would just point out that the end of the
American century has predicted to be coming
to an end for about the last
40 years, ever since the 70s.
And yet it continues.
We may finally with the rise of a powerful
China see things change but I think
that really has more to do with Chinese
history than American history at this point.
That would be my personal take on it.
I'm not exactly sure what
Woodrow Wilson would say.
I think he would probably be very optimistic
about America's prospects for the future,
as many of the American presidents
from the early 20th century
were, like Theodore Roosevelt.
>> Alright.
Well we hope that we've at least piqued
your interest about Wilson, his decisions,
his influence on American history
and foreign policy even today.
So with that, we're at the bottom of
the hour so I think we'll wrap up.
And Sahr, if you can pull the slideshow back up,
I do want to remind everyone
that this is part of a series.
So there will be more webinars to come.
But also, [inaudible] the Wilson papers
when they become available online.
But in the meantime, there are two webinars
on World War I, one November 28th looking
at Joseph Pennell who was
a printmaker in World War I
and specifically his prints left Liberty Parish
an evocative image of New York City destroyed
by the enemy which was created for
the 4th Liberty Loan Drive of 1918.
This will be by Catherine Vlaud of the Princeton
Photographs division November 28th at 2:00.
And December 12th at 2:00, Sahr's fellow
curator of the exhibition and fellow historian
in the manuscript division, Ryan Reft, will
present Charles Hamilton Houston on World War I,
looking at Houston's work experience as a young
officer serving in the segregated military
and the influence of those experiences
on his later work in civil rights,
including as chief attorney of the
NAACP and a mentor to Thurgood Marshall.
And of course you can register
for those sessions
by the World War I exhibition
website at loc.gov/exhibits.
I'll put in the chat a few more resources
by Sahr if you'd like to read more
of his thoughts on the Wilson papers.
And we'll also share -- it's on the next
slide -- the survey for today's webinar.
We hope you'll tell us what
you think of today's event.
And hopefully you'll join us
again for future sessions.
And with that we'll wrap up.
Thank you all so much for joining us.
I hope you enjoy it.
[ Background Discussions ]
Thanks, Connie.
And there's the webinar link.
So if you can take a minute, we'd appreciate it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.